with Metro Exodus developer for a games
had the unenviable task of building upon
a masterpiece too punishing to break
into the mainstream yet too bold to fade
into irrelevance the Metro series is a
sort of counter culture within the FPS
genre while most shooters strive for
thrills momentum and that ever elusive
flow state Metro relies on slower pacing
and painstaking attention to detail the
series second entry Last Light was the
peak of this philosophy and in my
opinion one of the finest shooters to
date that's why the franchise's newest
installment is so fascinating
Metro Exodus is the work of a studio
that already mastered its craft six
years ago but instead of chasing last
light's brilliance for a decided to
further toy with genre conventions
Exodus is the work of a developer that
now more than ever is comfortable
breaking the rules if you played Exodus
then you know it's a series of survival
sandboxes bookended by more traditional
linear shooter levels you'll fight your
way through a subterranean hideout
before emerging into a massive desert
where you can spend hours scavenging for
supplies Exodus as predecessors had
glimpses of this general shape in fact
some of last lights better sections were
these mini sand boxes that gave you the
freedom to approach from numerous angles
oftentimes with subtle stealthy methods
they elevated the pacing to the flawless
pitch that it was supplementing tight
corridors with spacious playgrounds last
light was brilliant in the way it
seamlessly blended these two formats but
Exodus is intriguing for kind of exactly
the opposite it's less about how these
structures can flow into one another
than how they can play off of one
another like to jazz musicians taking
turns with their solos take Exodus is
first open area the Volga it's a
radioactive waterlogged wasteland along
Europe's longest river it's littered
with hostile mutants and electrical
pulse phantoms it is as inviting as the
rest of the series which is to say not
at all
your map is free of quest indicators
until you train your binoculars on
distant landmarks or gather Intel from
your Spartan teammates the only methods
of travel are in a rowboat or on foot
both of which pose their own dangers
despite its general openness however
there are discrete linear missions
within the Volga when you first come
across a cult of zealous technophobes
you find yourself trapped in their
headquarters it's a maze of dark corners
in interlocking catwalks and fighting or
sneaking your way out becomes a
self-contained level of its own once
you're out you're back in the Voges open
expanse suddenly you're thinking
differently again the volga is about
big-picture problems are there likely to
be mutants in that valley ahead do I
have the right weapons for this Trek
across the map well these three oxygen
canisters suffice until the next
workbench the cults hideout however was
more about immediate concerns
extinguishing the lights making it to
that door landing this kill with my
throwing knife looking back that's where
much of my enjoyment of Exodus stems
from how well each sandbox each linear
mission requires a different school of
thought it's also remarkable how well
for a builds expectations with each area
only to question them with the next the
Volga is clever in how its watery
passageways funnel you from one mission
to the next but the Caspian Desert
thrusts you into a more traditional open
world you come across quests organically
by speaking with fellow travelers or
listening to the local radio station
it's almost as if Exodus is critiquing
itself as it goes claustrophobic
shootouts can grow stale so for a sweeps
them aside for sandbox stealth freeform
exploration can be boring so for a
brings you back underground where
monsters wait in the dark it's more than
just expert pacing it's a constant
willingness to question what came before
and it carries you along for the ride
to be clear exodus does stumble along
the way it has an array of technical
problems and certain missions that
overstay their welcome it's also too on
the nose with some of its story elements
and relies a bit too heavily on
exposition for my taste but by the time
you reach the taiga Metro Exodus is
final open area for a has you exactly
where it wants you if the most confined
sandbox yet with narrow forest paths and
dilapidated cabins it's less about
exploring your surroundings than it is
about learning how to use them to your
advantage for reasons I won't spoil here
it tests everything you've learned about
the game survival systems thus far and
also asks you how much of a pacifist
you're willing to be in such a harsh
world at for a saved its most
traditional open world for last it
probably would have stumbled by letting
you slowly explore at such a late stage
in the story it might have wrecked the
pacing of the final hours instead it
blends its traditional linearity with
occasional bouts of exploration he
reminds you of where the series came
from without sacrificing where it is
right now it builds momentum as the game
hurtles towards its conclusion and here
in its final moments for a is at its
peak I find it fitting that Metro
evolved by leaving the tunnels its
identity was built on to use an
appropriate metaphor or Exodus is less
about the linearity of train tracks and
more about the possibility of careening
off them at a moment's notice all of
this combines to give me the impression
that for a loves what it does
it loves shooters it loves taking risks
with level design it loves dangerous
worlds with brief shimmers of humanity
and in exodus these things are all
subject to scrutiny having finished
Metro Exodus I can't help but reflect on
how far the franchise has come for a has
never been shy about its inspirations it
has cited half-life 2 as one of its
guiding predecessors with story driven
combat and a willingness to bend the
rules
well while Metro 2033 and last light
were chasing Valve's seminal shooter
Exodus has an identity altogether its
own it feels like the work of a
developer who has adored studied and
mastered a genre
is now comfortable with experimentation
it doesn't always work but it's
fascinating to see unfold
[Music]